[Musica]
benvenuti solita routine sovranità in
italia è oggi nuova challenge che ci
avete consigliato poi un altro colore
challenge cioè tre colori di neve finta
ne vedete tutte cose bellissime sembrati
una granita e poi tre colori di glitter
qua dietro allora come funziona come
tutte le challenger tre colori dovremmo
bendarci pescare una volta un colore di
velocità e di glitter poi andremo a
mischiare il tutto nello slang vediamo
come diventa in questo sono troppo
curioso perché entri modo il gene uno
strato di neve tinta in più colorata
quindi non è l'idea di come diventerà la
slide diventerà super su no oppure
diventare una sorta di turismi non lo so
come diventerà the curiosa si sono per
fortuna che il blu e bici come il
colonnello di bab lug
per dire una cosa che abitano e non
piace la divertita non lo so perché non
ci piace la consistenza quindi sono
ancora allo slittamento che magari non
riuscirà perché hanno bene lo so poi
sicuramente il tè schifoso sarebbe più
bello sarà il vuoto
[Applauso]
volete vedere altre tre colori
attrezzate in slide continuate a
consigliarti nei commenti che al prezzo
allen se volete vedere le più belle
ville sono un cuoricino e andremo a
farle
[Applauso]
primo round fronti carta forze nato ciao
aspetto vizio fosse
[Applauso]
[Musica]
state inventate ad abitare allora sono
tutti qua
ok allora io politico direttamente
dall'alto si questa cosa ha specificato
commentato così cosa mai
ecco quattro sì questo prima la sua
faccia il mio unico lotto sommerge di 96
possono arrivare al primo turno che poi
ci sono anche tutte queste che voleva la
bella raffaella più parte di cai
perché se tutto il colorante dentro
quindi sono certo solo siamo tolto
speriamo riesca un bel blog di s.barbara
la grigia a venderglielo di tratti sono
nata e che sta facendo davvero tutto
aiuto pronta nokia che vediamo
che bello come fai tu come noi contiamo
di far uscire un bel marrone dei monti
mare allora dobbiamo ammettere il primo
ingrediente cioè non aver finto di
questo colore vediamo già come diventare
un fax mai
ecco a guardate che bella persona di
finta arancione andiamo subito a
metterla sotto non si era colorata me
rimarrà la picchiava
se diamo già un po come diventa
sembra una beta governo tira mondo
allora vediamo come lo colora sta
colorando di arancione però il colore
non è molto forte quindi una sorta di
arancione chiaro da st capito il rosso
corsi rompe alma chrome e nette sembra
uno yogurt a 1
la pesca bello bello non vedo l'ora di
attivarlo tutto verde vai la memorabile
[Risate]
slime alla menta nel mio ovviamente sarà
fortissimo come colore e quindi
riguardante che il verde sempre
fortissima e acido nella lista non è
fortissimo lavorando tantissimo ho
quindi vediamo cos'altro ti capita come
un gioco che facciamo ai tweet ai media
utilizza carta forse troppo la sam
prevedibile ma come allora per i glitter
vaio mischiarli va bene can't fight ha
fatto allora i glitter sono qua con le
sceglie questa volta penso che vado al
centro
prendo questo richiamo sia andato vicino
al grasso lastrico campata di poco però
che bello non lancia non ci fa bene
[Musica]
[Applauso]
farebbe credere il verde per festeggiare
il titolo perde contro che mettiamo i
glitter blu vediamo come ci stanno in
questo line neri erezione mamma mia che
coi brutti perché bellissima ma giunto a
riadattare la ragione quando avete era
ben effetti un po strano adesso va detto
però una volta attivo vedrai quanto sarà
bello a particolare effettivamente
vedremo una volta attivo come diventa io
adesso aggiungo i miei bellissimi
glitter dorate che belli bellissimi
il colore è già aperto così per lo verde
tornavano molto ancora è un bebè dorato
vediamo un po come diventa bello come
devo diventare bene adesso round e
sanremo con la neve finta vediamo chi
inizia cassaforte sasso che denota
regolarvi a me queste belle rotta viola
sta bene con la religione in realtà si
nota già fischiato allora stanno da qui
a qui ok quale sceglie
[Musica]
com'è stato detto che qui vediamo un po
e quello che volevo rosa è bellissima
questa inter viola io del suo software
che mescola sul quale vorrei solo per un
problema anche in cortese rosso diventa
padroneggiando niente blu il blu forse
forse forse seria ma che diventi canale
dimmiquando è fatto da fare ok quindi tu
volevi non te lo dico più 73 qua dentro
questo proprio il primo secondo terzo
posso dire niente ormai lei preso
trascurabile che non volervi è stata che
diventi marrone ha del tutto slide viola
e fucsia il dott
speriamo che lo colori bene questa volta
vediamo
[Musica]
belli di moda la consistenza sembra
davvero una granita un frullato bo
comunque bellissimo del fucino
frappuccino e rota è in rotta proprio
fragolino che bello il mila migliorato
stacco perché mitico vogliono un sacco
dialogo bello questo rosso tipo gravità
l'anguria ma la guri n
marrone ma speriamo però marrone terra
sembra proprio l'anguria effettivamente
della rossa e verde della buccia ci
mettiamo solo dei seminari smile
manduria per cui ma sto diventato grigio
la curia in cui tutto normale ma non è
il grande record colore grigio
vediamo tutto il fortunato magari se ti
capita il blu riesce a recuperarlo con
il giallo non merito ancora più marroni
c 8 round questa volta con i glitter e
ultimo round tra l'altro quindi vediamo
che bendati destro investe un bel colore
valgano migliori quale colore ti
piacerebbe ma donadoni non c'è quindi
coloro il capitolo diego parte sterrato
dove lo metti non farlo
stiamo ricordando i cantieri che lo dico
solo quando non esco
come mai a sapere dove lo metto perché
tu sei furba davvero pronti sono tutti
qui e ora invece il cielo proprie
fortune media atto no stati fatto allora
partono da qui a qui perché mirca viola
rosso viola rosa viola doppio questo tra
desio per prendere un occhio nero mezzo
lo sanno bene che bel viola video in cui
di mettermi la morosa benissimo
comportato come tina ma il vero nome di
ruby dire ora che bello con tutti i
posti riflessi viola
mettiamo con il viola come diventa
ancora più che fortunato migliori da
quando attivi fine che giudico teheran
grido marsi no dipende tutto da cosa mi
capita adesso come metro di bellissimo
abbiamo range attivano tutti va così che
sto scuola in pit bubble che bello
aspetta aspetta che questo ne sono altri
due aspettare chissà quale però è che la
marina tra il giallo o sarà in loro nomi
da titolare altri hanno il tuo ha detto
ecco i miei glitter non c'entrano niente
questo blu letto un momentino ma magari
gli danno un po di colore a questo
grigio come caluria grigia
[Musica]
forse forse forse è ancora più strano
stanno migliorando oppure peggiorando
questo colore strano colore nero e di
tutta la infortunato se ti capita non il
giallo
credo proprio di sì più importante ci
vediamo kilic casa bruciata cappotto mai
che ti capiti i blu quindi per salvarla
9 sì le mie non so se ci sta meglio ok
italiano più come dire vieni metterò
vana quadro è bellissimo però purtroppo
non penso che si stia mentendo
indovinate di come chi secondo voi di
che colore diventa ma non era né come ti
prego che bene
e bellissimo il colore però vediamo un
po no non marrone marrone non usciva
allora finora non sta diventato star
amalgamando bene si sta diventando
celeste è fortunato aspetta aspetta
stato direttore grito cristo grillo oggi
era gioverà di no lui è ancora rosati
botta per diventare grigio si capisse
che colore è mai mosso rosa con un po di
sfumature blues ha poi si è diventato un
po violetto scuro è vero perché blu rosa
lo fa diventare viola prende il mio
diventato villa era che con una mano
fortunata la fine vediamo taxi e la
scuola questa data dai ho l'impressione
che diventi ancora pubblici
[Risate]
è vestito di grigio grigio con
riflessioni già detto volere questa
mamma mi ha capito dai magari una volta
attivo di vendermi un bel faccino che
ricambia completamente
che bellissimo che ora di marley bello
proprio perchè i ragazzi andiamo ad
attivarli come sempre è poi ve li
possiamo vedere dovrete votare se vinco
giustizia vitale in base all'aspetto
pezzoni smr stiamo frasi 32 o il colore
mi piace un sacco
allora vi faccio vedere meglio per tempo
al consistenza si vedono tutti i
granelli li della neve finta e
ovviamente la neve finta messa prima fa
un effetto diverso rispetto a metterla
dopo un pò diverso schino e poi non era
tantissima quindi è rimasto più tipo una
granita mi piace un sacco perché super
sufficiente per allungabile super
soffice il colore mi piace tantissimo
questo violetto di la chiamerò stata
fortunata per il colore e poi sentite i
suoni
bellissimo mi piace il fatto che
consiste il tetto è proprio diversa da
visto che facciamo in genere sembra
quasi con la trasparenza quindi quel
perché il nome di amore per l'attività
letta slide che fu il che è il pad
devo prendermi raro di tutta la sua
bellezza
il colore è un po particolare può
sembrare quasi vaniglia
si vede che ci sono tutti i puntini
della bottiglia ed è un pochino e
migliorate un po meno e quasi stupendo
non va bene è bellissimo e super super
allungabile super morbidoso quasi fla
foto
comunque montino è migliorato colore
orrendo l'impatto della pizza si basa
persona e mozzarella per la pizza una
focaccia dell'altra procaccio tornare
con l'olio dello smarino allora che fare
benvenuta adesso è niente quindi direi
che il mio bello da noi ecco la legalità
italiani da acquisire dati e tanto
carino però il mio nuovo e più vanitoso
per quasi pezzetto zoe o gassoso e un
furioso per belli un po scorreggione
così sembrava sembra ok dei fatti un
pallino sembra quasi di pasta pasta da
pane o da pizza allora questo è lo slime
imparino belle linee così una così ora
così abbiamo fatto il filone timore di
pare filone di pane
insomma ce la facevo un bel paninazzo
che mai
allora votate quando sondaggisti dico io
lo dice pizzetta metti al forno di gela
su to be like dovresti vedere altre
challenge e ora fatto che the lines e
poi cliccare per vedere le nostre tre
challenge il video di ieri i battenti i
nostri slime cliccate su questo c'è